it is time to own up to our obsessions
weird or not for the first time in our
New York City Studio I love being here
I'm going to hit this button and a topic
will be selected by our super random
super computer which apparently followed
us from La um then the person obsessed
with the topic will own up and sell us
on their Obsession I will get us started
here we go
okay
oh
I share this Obsession you are we going
to do it next season you want to do it
will happily be in your fantasy oh my
God oh my gosh we should do it I'm I
it's my first season I'm obsessed Lester
happened to kick my behind this last
weekend but I didn't really know the
players as well and now I'm obsessed now
I'm like watching games that were on
weeks ago just to study up yeah wow
you're really you're going I'm really
into it because I like a game you see
Andrew yeah and fantasy football is fun
he keeps trying to get me to watch the
sports I will literally
I'll be I'll be on Sundays we our show
starts at 3 I'll be backstage watching
on my iPad football games absolutely and
Andrew will walk by and go you watching
sports ball again exactly I couldn't do
it this year because I'm so committed to
work yeah you're very so I have it well
I am not committed to work and I was
like I'm doing it I'll I'll play your
yes it's so fun if you like a
game
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home